en quoi cette journée du 8 mars est
importante pour vous
parce que c'est une journée où il faut
évoquer Thomas nous le savons c'est
droit des femmes partout sur la planète
oui mais encore d'accord
la journée de la flamme le PSG qui joue
ce soir contre le Bayern quand même on
pensait qu'ils avaient touché le fond
les anges 20 avec le résultat
cataclysmique en championnat dernier de
Ligue 1 avec 10 points pris sur 78 mais
le club creuse encore avec la phrase
choquante du coach Abdel Bouazza ma ce
weekend avant la défaite 5-0 à
Montpellier en causerie d'avant match
pour justifier la titularisation d'Ilyes
chety un défenseur a reconnu qui a
reconnu des attouchements sur une femme
en boîte de nuit la déclaré ceci c'est
pas méchant on a tous déjà touché des
filles c'est la journée alors c'est pas
dire la journée des femmes la journée
des droits de la journée des femmes
portant un utérus
[Rires]
une journée qui nous rappelle
l'importance de continuer à se battre
pour les droits des femmes en France et
dans le monde entier voilà le 8 mars
c'est tous les jours c'est pas que le 8
mars quand on se regarde on se désole
France c'est vrai et un des pays
l'égalité salariale et la plus
à côté de l'Afghanistan on s'en sort
bien elles sont une quinzaine seulement
et pour cause il faut bien du courage
pour braver les talibans en cette
journée de la femme le temps est venu
pour les Nations Unies de prendre une
décision décisive et sérieuse concernant
le sort du peuple afghan ces afghans
demandent de l'aide contre les
injustices dont elles sont victimes
depuis le retour des talibans à l'été
2021 j'aimerais quoi
un jour mon mari est arrivé avec des
talibans ils m'ont dit que selon mon
mari le divorce avait été obtenu par la
force qu'il ne voulait pas divorcer ils
n'ont pas voulu entendre ce que je leur
disais ils m'ont demandé de leur montrer
les papiers du divorce lorsque je les ai
apporté ils les ont déchirés pas titre
symbolique l'Union européenne a adopté
des sanctions contre le ministre afghan
de l'enseignement supérieur les talibans
ont interdit entre autres aux femmes
d'aller à l'université vous êtes sur RMC
il est 10h et quelques minutes
et interdisent
dramatique Olivier Truchot qui passe
devant la caméra je balance et medigezar
aussi à leur je suis en train de enfin
si de pas y aller ma chère claire je te
présente toutes mes excuses pour cette
classe turbulente le 8 mars 1917 des
ouvrières russes lancent une grande
grève qui mènera à l'abdication du tsar
c'est le premier jour de la révolution
russe les soviétique font alors du 8
mars un symbole de la puissance des
femmes en Espagne a eu gain de cause son
ancien mari a été condamné à lui payer
plus de 200000 euros 24 ans de salaire
pour s'être notamment occupé du travail
domestique pendant leur mariage cette
décision judiciaire trouve de l'écho sur
les réseaux sociaux elle est saluée et
l'on appelle la justice française à
faire de même cette internaute tempère
revenu au moins c'est pas cher payé mais
pour certains cette décision pourrait
bien servir d'électrochoc et c'est 4 ans
plus tard le 8 mars 1921 que Lénine
décrète cette date comme la Journée
internationale des femmes en Russie
cette journée donc particulièrement
célébré c'est même un jour férié
aujourd'hui de Vladimir Poutine
organisait une cérémonie au Kremlin
Daniel Moreau qui vient de nous
rejoindre qui est magnifique en direct
on dirait
la phrase la plus sexiste entendue dans
le milieu du rap
et la moule j'aimerais bien l'avoir bien
transparente aussi essayer d'avoir
vraiment cette moule qu'on puisse voir à
travers
Chiré
sachez que les femmes polluent moins que
les hommes c'est un constat mais elles
sont plus victimes du changement
climatique c'est ça c'est même plus
qu'un constat c'est une étude qui va
sortir aujourd'hui réalisé par une
économie spécialisée dans le climat qui
nous dit quoi que l'épaule les femmes
polluent moins produisent moins de CO2
que les hommes majoritairement à cause
de quoi à cause de quoi alors barbecue
il
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
sur des plateformes digitales comme
Alibaba des femmes surtout vendent des
vêtements comme dans un télé-achat à
l'ancienne elle vendent notamment de la
lingerie et pour en faire la réclame
elle joue parfois les mannequins elle
porte donc elle-même la lingerie les
chiffres le montrent en France il y a
2,2 % de végétariens et parmi ces 2,2%
de végétariens 67% de deux tiers plus de
2/3 sont des femmes donc les femmes sont
plus sensibles en tout cas moins
sensibles à la consommation de viande
rouge est plus sensible à ce qui en ce
qui concerne le le véganisme j'allais
dire oui végétarien manger autre chose
que de la viande rouge les autorités
chinoises ont décidé que les farm
n'auraient plus le droit désormais de
porter la lingerie sur ces plateformes
alors c'est une décision qui met en
péril le revenu de nombreuses femmes
chinoises c'est pas anodin
[Musique]